each
[Music]
[Applause]
is the popular Chris Sims pro football
talk live co-host former NFL quarterback
joining us on the program let me start
with the saquon Barkley deal we like to
have a who won and who lost so can you
give a win or a loss in this situation
to anybody I don't know if you really
can Dan you're right I mean you know the
Giants won I guess I'm gonna say they
won but I also think like saquon Barkley
won as well like I sat here in the seat
yesterday you know doing the show with
Florio doing my podcast a little later
banging the table for going sequan don't
do this you know what I'm a Giants fan
but two I'm a really big saquon Barkley
fan as a player and the person he's done
everything right you know the sit out or
training camp sit out a year wait till
next year thing it never works right you
lose your your your your craft you lose
your explosive ability that you never
get back so I'm just just glad he got in
there and he's getting his money you're
never going to get that back he's got
that and yeah the Giants win because
he's the most explosive player on their
offense and they got him back on the
offense and back on the team here any
Fallout that could affect other running
backs well I mean it's
it's a the running back Market this is
something I've been talking about really
for quite some time but how do we get
here Chris how did we get where they're
so devalued that right you know it's a
it's a great question you know and and
you know I think here's here would be
the start of it in in my opinion one
Mike Shanahan and the Zone running
system right that did that that was the
first time we went whoa this scheme they
get yards for everybody okay it's 2 000
yards or Terrell Davis but we can put
Johnny who the hell is this running back
and he gets 1400 yards so that I think
was the start of it right then you know
you look at the last 20 years the
greatest team we saw in the sport for
the last 20 years they never had a
marquee running back they did there
early with Corey Dillon but then it went
you know running back by committee
through the rest of the Patriots dynasty
right you look at the Chiefs they've
been to three to the last four Super
Bowls has three different running backs
you know in three of those Super Bowls I
think some of the Hydra draft picks who
have flamed out or bodies have gotten
injured bad contracts Ezekiel Elliott
Todd Gurley things like that I think it
all has kind of got us here to that
moment and last but most important Dan
offensive coordinators have found ways
to you know manipulate offense despite
who the running back is right hey well
we got more wide receiver screens we got
another wide receiver screen we gotta
tight on the screen we got a speed sweep
we got a reverse we can put Debo Samuel
a tail back for a few plays so they have
found ways to make up for not having
Adrian Peterson or some star stud at
that position and I think that's what's
led us to where we are right now is
there um any room on the hype train for
the Jets or the Lions
uh well
yeah the Jets I I will say I have less
questions about the Jets the Jets are
more about can they gel together you
know can Aaron Rodgers and all the
receivers get on the same page and more
about you know they're just it's it's I
think I said to you in the spring the
AFC East is as good as I've ever seen it
I don't remember it ever the afcs let
alone the AFC in general right so I
don't know where that's going to put
them but I think the hype should be real
about them there's not really many
position groups you can look at their
team and go I'm not sure about that the
Lions you know they're the ones I'm a
little bit more worried about you know
one I know the offense was good but how
good right I know the offensive line is
good I still question Jared Goff to a
degree it's easy to put up a lot of
points and yards when you know your
defense is just going to let points and
yards up all the time and you're kind of
always in a shootout and then of course
the defense yeah got questions about
them as well they were last in football
last year so you know the lions are the
team that I worry maybe a little bit
more than the Jets about handling the
Limelight and the uh all the attention
here how does it go wrong for the Jets
I think
you know get out of the gates poorly
right got a tough schedule and they they
certainly could be sitting there going
whoa we're one and two we're one and
three you know you have that Rogers gets
dinged up a little bit right then all
the naysayers oh why did we trade for
him and do give them all the
compensation and it just all starts to
pile on that's how I would kind of look
at it to to go south right uh I don't
expect it to but but I think that would
be one way I would see it happening
talking to Chris Sims pro football talk
live co-host former NFL quarterback
contributes to football night in America
the Packers I think are on record saying
that they're going to give Jordan love
sort of half the season to figure out
what they have
shouldn't they know what they have with
Jordan love
before you're going to say I got a eight
or nine games yeah I mean I think they
know to a degree there's expectations
their optimism but you know as you know
Dan right I mean you just don't really
know until it's the weekend week out
grind oh teams have figured out what
we're doing on offense and what Jordan
love likes to throw what's going to be
the next adjustment oh we had two or
three weeks of not very good offensive
play and everybody in the National media
in the Green Bay media is all over
Jordan love how is he gonna handle that
but how many times as many camps as you
were in yeah did you look at a
quarterback and then it didn't translate
into success on the field or vice versa
where you go oh my God I thought this
guy was going to be so great or I didn't
realize he was going to be so great can
you detect how good a quarterback's
going to be by being around him for a
couple of years in practice are you deaf
definitely can you can you can you can
pick up a lot from that well you know
one the talent itself and I think Jordan
love has that talent I think he's got a
lot of the mannerisms and you know the
personality like we see where he seems
to be very even keeled they know that
too right so I think there's and and so
so all of that yes you can look at that
and go hey I think we got something here
right it's kind of what Atlanta's doing
with Desmond Ritter they don't know but
they're going wait we like a lot of the
things this guy's made of so we're gonna
give it a shot here and see if we can go
with it the Packer Situation's a little
different yes right
um but yeah I still think it goes back
to okay right all right we like all
these things but now it's getting you
know tough and The Season's getting
tough and we've gone through some tough
times is he gonna handle be able to
handle it he's made some bad mistakes
the last two games is he gonna come out
in game three and now be gun shy or is
he gonna come out and be able to play
his game or is it going to be totally
affected and not be the same so I think
those are the things you gotta get
answer I don't think you can really
answer them until you know you get
through the thick and thin of the NFL
season a little bit Justin Fields uh has
a goal of 4 000 passing yards
that's that's a big goal who's he
throwing to
well you know when Darnell Mooney gets
back healthy he's he can go right Chase
Claypool has Superstar traits yeah you
know I think it's well yeah it's the
other stuff with Chase Claypool it's the
immaturity off the field and some of
that stuff but like when I tell you when
Adonis of Adonis is Dan Patrick like
Chase Claypool one of those guys if he
walked in your studio you'd be like holy
crap that's Chase Claypool right and he
can fly and then DJ Moore is a superstar
if DJ Moore is not on the Carolina
Panthers the last few years he is you
know considered one of the top receivers
at least for my money so I'm excited for
that pairing there they drafted the Kid
vs Jones versus Jones last year in the
draft they got cold committed tight end
so there's some things to work with
there but yeah his big question is can
he stand in the pocket and make good
throw after good throw consistently with
the decisions that go and that that are
needed we had that's the thing we need
to see from Justin Fields this year in
year three
uh obj says that this could be his last
year
I don't buy it it's just attention did
he did he pick up on what I was laying
down to get attention talking about
retirement with my career and he decided
that he was going to one-up me well I
mean you know when Dan Patrick speaks we
all try to jump off of Dan Patrick I
mean you've set the standard for
coolness out there right so right uh but
no I think obj
um I know him a little bit through his
years here in New York and got a chance
to spend some time with him in an
interview in Cleveland and the Rams and
stuff like that the the passion for the
sport is so real and intense that I
think what he went through the last year
or two as he said was you know like a
huge blow to his soul you know this is a
guy that again he wasn't just like here
to be oh I'm a good receiver and I'm
gonna make some money in the NFL this is
a guy that like I talked to in year two
of his career Nick he was flat out I
want to be the best receiver in the
history of football and was on that
trajectory so I would say he has a
positive year here they're going to win
some games Baltimore is going to be good
he has good stats that's going to
reinvigorate that love and he's gonna go
wait what the hell else am I going to do
if I don't play football I can still run
4-3 and be the man out here so uh I
don't buy it once we get going I'm just
talking about defensive backs who's a
Hall of Famer who's a recent retiree
Hall of Famer who is maybe a Hall of
Famer in waiting at the defensive back
position okay that's that's a good
question you're catching me on the Fly
here but all right so
um you know here's one that I got for
you that I don't know if people put the
Aqib Talib would be a DB that I would
say he's a Hall of Famer for my money
okay Aqib Talib what he did for the
Broncos helping them win a Super Bowl
help the Patriots win a Super Bowl right
I was in Tampa Bay when we drafted him
he was literally down a day one first
day of training camp like holy crap he's
matching up against the number one
receiver her and not just like doing
okay like he's dominating practice and
got two interceptions our first training
camp practice so to me and he's one of
those guys you just go hey you got him
all game long that would be one that
just jumps off you know uh my mind right
off the bat you know Jalen Ramsey of
course is headed that way I think uh
there's some probably some other guys
I'm missing too I'm choking under the
pressure but Stefan Gilmore uh Gilmore I
think is going to be yes I think he will
be in that conversation as well no doubt
about it yeah
um I think he will be when it's all said
and done we know that quarterbacks would
stay away from Rivas Dion Sanders did
you have a DB that you purposely stayed
away from yeah well I mean I didn't play
enough I wasn't good enough to always
deal with that I was in a lot of
meetings where they were telling the
starting quarterback not to do that
right and I was like oh okay yeah that's
right if I get in there I'm not throwing
at him don't worry but but um well I can
tell you Champ Bailey in practice and
when I was with the Denver Broncos would
scare the crap out of me I mean he just
he had great intellect he had great
acceleration he can mess with your mind
so that was always scary namdi awesome
Wah in his prime with the Raiders we
were getting ready to play them Josh
McDaniels the Denver Broncos on that
football team we he literally told us on
a Tuesday when we had a quarterback
meeting he just said just if Nam days
over here we're throwing over here we're
not doing it it's not worth it so that
was probably like the biggest one in my
day uh as far as the one I had a face
off of that scared me for sure good to
talk to you as always Bud we'll talk to
you soon all right man be good say hi to
the guys uh Chris Sims pro football talk
live co-host with Mike Florio you can
see that show it precedes hours on
peacock